alright ready for some humor black lives
matters
that's the humor no sorry black lives
matters thinks it can bring down white
capitalism by creating a black Christmas
and their idea is for black consumers to
boycott any white owned stores so tell
me how is that not racist and don't
people like Hillary Clinton former
President Obama ultimately share some
blame for helping legitimize such a
radical organization just listen
black lives matter simply refers to the
notion that there's a specific
vulnerability for African Americans that
needs to be addressed when people say
black lives matter that doesn't mean
blue lives don't matter and we do have
to stand up and say loudly and clearly
black lives matter all right joining us
now for reaction is attorney Anthony
hall all right Anthony you got it you
got to educate me on this one I do not
understand this at all how do you
determine first of all just as a factual
matter if a business let's say is owned
by like an Indian guy and a partnership
with a white woman and then maybe has a
has a black like co-owner as well maybe
three people owned a business together
does that business get boycotted because
there's an element other than a black
element in the ownership structure how
do you determine that well I don't know
if that's how you focus on the problem I
think you pretty much just focus on what
they're saying is that there's black
businesses in the black community that
need to be supported and need to be
encouraged you know this is a day of
Oprah this is the day of blackish you
know black economic power means
something so what black lives matter is
saying is let's just invest in black
businesses for this Christmas let's make
sure we spend our dollar the way that a
lot of other ecklie's groups have spent
their dollars for years so I don't know
if the focus is so much on whether or
not there's a diversity or an want that
culture within the business or excluding
whites I think the focus is on let's
make sure that our economic dollar is
spent in our community and we build
entrepreneurship which is a Republican
idea I'm surprised you don't like
Laura yeah well I actually think it's
people want to the catholics go to
catholic businesses you know i have any
problem with that my problem is when it
seems to be based in a in a very it's
kind of a negative thing Christmas is
about you know christ and the birth of
christ and of course retail is important
but i think businesses need need need
consumers they need customers so why
penalize a business that just happens to
be owned in whole or part by a white
person maybe that white person or indian
person or asian person may be pulled
himself or herself up by the bootstraps
came from nothing and started a business
in a minority community don't we want to
encourage white and asian and all sorts
of people to come in to black
communities to bring more dollars an
investment that way black people can
come work there and maybe become a
manager and ultimately take the take the
shop over isn't that something good well
yeah that's good but I think I think
because black people in this country
have had such a economic struggle
remember this is nothing new going all
the way back to black Wall Street in
Tulsa rosewood where blacks would try to
start their own businesses which could
expand and could express the diversity
that you're talking about and a lot of
those communities were destroyed so with
that being the case we're still here in
2017 where now we realize the black
dollar has economic power as always hold
on I say green dollars what I mean black
dollars I mean I definitely I definitely
understand what is a dollar spent at any
at any store retail outlet I mean that
dollar goes into the business in the
community so I understand spend money in
the community I think that's great
because it encourages more business
Courage's more jobs and so forth that's
great
but it just seems antithetical to me to
helping a community where people are
coming in from all races and backgrounds
whether it's st. Louis or Detroit it
isn't it about welcoming people of all
colors and backgrounds into different
privileged underserved areas and
bringing all people together it's not
what Christmas is all about not like
you're black I'm wide you're Asian let's
all go to our own stores and go to our
own separate places to me that's just
that's just wild after after yeah I
don't think that's the point I know I
don't think that's the point though I
think the point is that what they're
saying let me go back to the black
dollar thing what I'm saying is that
black people who have money which is
obviously green that their dollars go
into black businesses there's nothing
wrong with that there's nothing wrong
with saying that if you live in a
certain community let's support the
businesses in the black you're making it
about race and I think this is the stuff
that and and and when you say black
people should shop only at black owned
stores that is a racial statement at a
time where country is supposed to be
uniting coming together especially at
the holiday season and if it was gonna
be really focused on only black
businesses why just focus during
Christmas make it all year long forever
I only go to black owned stores only a
lot of black owned businesses do it'll
hold your lawn I think it should we do
it right I think it should be that way I
think it should be that way but I think
again I think you're missing the point
no no that's not what I'm saying what
I'm saying is there should not be there
should be a diversity of dollars spent
but because of those people who are at a
low economic level to build their dollar
value up in other communities they need
to learn how to invest in their own
business everyone needs to learn to have
a work ethic save save for a rainy day
and be open to people of different
backgrounds and different and I just
think the racial line is wild I think
it's it's like the opposite meaning of
Christmas at least to me but you know I
think that's how you see it yeah I
appreciate it thanks so much